Universal plans to launch a monster
movie universe on the back of Tom Cruise
as The Mummy the flick serves as a
reboot of both the studio's classic
scary movie franchise and the brendan
fraiser starring trilogy
however despite a lofty expectations and
the attachment of a huge starring cruise
The Mummy wasn't able to scare up many
viewers in its opening weekend debuting
to an underwhelming 31 point five
million dollars domestic gross as it
turns out nobody but crews have said
this Jeremy the mummy
the disappointing starts that a thriller
likely won't completely unravel universe
a so-called dark universe but it
definitely spells trouble he is why the
mummy was dead on arrival critical curse
The Mummy was absolutely trashed by
critics quickly falling below a 20
percent on Rotten Tomatoes during its
debut weekend indieWIRE called the film
an irredeemable disaster from start to
finish an adventure that entertains only
via glimpses of the adventure it should
have been vulture said it hits its marks
but they're so low and so brazenly
mercenary that it doesn't feel like much
of an achievement rolling stone quipped
that it's a monster fail more than a V
club said it was noisy but rarely
exciting heavy on whizzing and whirling
special effects but light on wonder it's
hard to find anything positive critics
have said about the movie even those who
gave it fresh reviews mostly just beamed
at tolerable rather than actually
entertaining there's so many other
options out there viewers have little
reason to head out to a movie that
critics have so thoroughly buried
wrongheaded reboots the classic in 1932
The Mummy is a far far cry from the 2017
version something classic cinema fans
surely noticed when a trailer for the
new film dropped starring Boris Karloff
as the namesake monster the original
flick relied on quieter atmospheric
horrid I kept viewers on the edge of
their seats the felt aggressively trying
to scare them at every turn the new
movie on the other hand goes for near
constant CGI thrills that are more
visual surprises than actual scares fans
of the original will see almost nothing
familiar in the reboot and
audiences may be more familiar with
Brendan Fraser's mummy trilogy anyway
those movies emphasize can be fun and
had help selling its story with his
nineteen twenties setting which gave a
period appropriate feel to the classic
monster tale cruisers version meanwhile
takes place in the present day a move
that arguably takes the film even
further from the classic adventure story
it's trying to be rehash fatigue
Hollywood have spent the last several
years turning to familiar properties
audiences loved in the past but the
string of flops from 2017 properly
imaginings suggests film goers might be
getting tired of all the modern revivals
King Arthur legend of the sword Dwayne
the rock Johnson's Baywatch and v
Pirates of the Caribbean flick all fell
far below expectations all these films
have something in common
rotten reviews and bad word-of-mouth as
successful recent remakes reboots and
the sequels like Beauty and the Beast
and the fate of the Furious have shown
audiences are only willing to turn out
to see overly familiar films if they're
actually any good cart before horse
universals dark universe franchises set
to include beloved characters such as
the Invisible Man The Phantom of the
Opera and Frankenstein among many others
in denial well let's not be too hasty
doc the studio may have killed the whole
enterprise as chances of success by
announcing it before even making a
single successful film hobbling the
mummy and making its attempt at well
building seems disingenuous to audiences
of many of the reviews pointed out the
movie struggles of that world building
leaving the narrative feeling slow and
labored with heavy exposition
interrupting the action launching the
dark universe right off the bat without
trying to first create a successful fun
film played a big role in the mummy's
overcrowded feel and could have a
negative effect on the rest of the
franchise going forward star power
outage internationally big names like
Tom Cruise still sell movies but at home
data shows that people just don't care
as much about a movie star power as they
once did
recent examples include Dwayne Johnson
and Baywatch and Tom Hanks in the circle
high-profile flops highlighted by the
surprising performances of 2017 sleeper
it's like it gets out and split neither
of which had huge names attached so what
gives
to one thing more stars are moving to
movies on TV and streaming with huge
names like Brad Pitt crafting films for
Netflix and stars like Matthew
McConaughey and Nicole Kidman making
prestige TV like true detective and big
little lies the number of films and
theaters is also increasing meaning that
viewers simply have more to choose from
because need marketing is important but
organic versus what can really make a
film blow up and the mummy never really
had any a Fandango poll looking for the
most anticipated film of the summer
didn't even put it in the top five while
a look at social media birth on Twitter
showed that the film wasn't among the
top 5 most tweeted about movies the
months leading up to its release the
summer box office is overcrowded with
huge movies and without positive
word-of-mouth it's hard for one movie
even one with an established name like
The Mummy to break out what are you
thanking oh that kid was probably gonna
die here
no wonder making matters worse the mummy
faced one of the toughest competitors of
the summer during its opening weekend
Wonder Woman the juggernaut repeat the
box office with an expectation
shattering 103 million dollar opening
Wonder Woman also used its stellar
reviews to earn the biggest second week
for any film in the DC extended universe
franchise thus far The Mummy likely
couldn't have topped Wonder Woman second
week grosses even if it had received
positive reviews salvaged overseas the
box office market is very different
overseas and it's provided a rescue for
quite a few domestic flops in recent
years this looks to be the case for the
mummy which gave cruise the largest
international opening of his career the
film did best in crews from the
territories like China South Korea
Russia Mexico and Taiwan where the
star's name continues to carry quite a
lot of weight it's not an exact science
this business this may offer a lifeboat
for the future of the dark universe
which has a few other big-name stars
attached for upcoming movies including
Johnny Depp as the Invisible Man still
The Mummy scary lack of domestic appeal
as the troubling wrinkle to the future
of Universal monster movie initiative
thanks for watching click
lupa icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your nothing
[Music]